you know if we've done anything this
year we've uh certainly played a lot of
Tik Tok videos for better or worse and
so just to recap as we move in uh to uh
the next year which is sure to be even
worse than the last we're going to go
through what I would consider to be the
top 10 most irritating Tik toks of the
year it's very hard really difficult to
to narrow it down and uh so it's it's
maybe even impossible but we're going
with these 10 we'll play them and uh at
the end we will Crown the the the the
ultimate the the most annoying Tik Tok
of 2023 I feel like there's a lot of
there's a lot of my shoulders here uh
this is very important to get this right
and so I'll do my best but uh let's
start with the first one welcome to the
day in the life of a 24-year-old that
still lives with her appearance that us
why don't move out if I can afford to
and the truth is I am lazy so I made
these protein waffles for breakfast for
everyone and then I got ready to bully
my parents into buying things that I
want and I have to play with my new
toour okay I think we get the idea the
whole genre the whole Day in the Life
genre I feel like we could put in one
category like these videos they they
never get any better than that they they
never do anything interesting it's never
oh it's the day in of life we I went to
the International Space Station I
climbed Mount Everest I I don't know
it's never anything like that so it's
always the the most tedious pointless
activities you could possibly imagine
that are being documented in extensive
detail and in this case it's someone
who's an adult living at home so that's
pretty bad I don't know if it's the
worst but let's go to the next one if
you need to manifest something overnight
get nearly instant results to manifest a
text a call College acceptance to hear
good news this is one of the methods
that the people who are doing manifest
magic at the top of my page are using to
see results like this you and I are
going to be manifesting whatever it is
you desire during this video right here
right now y I tried it it doesn't the
the magic doesn't work I am sure every
Tik Tock influencer will float off into
space I am sure every Tik Tok influencer
will Flo float off into space you think
it's a it's a scan that couldn't last
very long because people are going to
discover that just because they sh say I
am sure such such going to happen that
doesn't mean it's going to happen like
once people discover that you think that
the scam breaks down but it doesn't
because either someone says uh you know
follows your manifesting tips and then
the thing happens because it was going
to happen anyway or if it doesn't work
then she could say well you didn't you
didn't tap into the frequency you got to
get you got to get into the manifesting
frequency and you just weren't you
didn't say it enough you didn't say it
loud enough so it's a scam it's also
annoying it's like it's one of those
scams you wish you had thought of that's
that's that's this is a real Contender
let's go to the next one I don't
remember the last time I went to see a
movie because I don't love going to the
movie theater but I'll tell you what it
pisses me off that I can't go see Barbie
so I'm doing a thing and if you live in
the Pacific Northwest you can do a thing
with me here's what it is someday next
week on a weekday I am renting out a
theater in Northwest Portland the entire
theater the theater seats 40 six people
I think we are only going to do 2 so me
and 19 I I remember this vividly because
when I saw this video come up on Twitter
whatever it was uh I I I spent a little
bit of time investigating this person
because I did at first I thought like
this can't be real there's no way that
the people like this still exist in the
world worried about Co she rented out
the entire theater I could not think of
a less appealing
invitation and this one does prove to be
pretty annoying because I had to just to
make sure it wasn't a parody I had to
investigate this woman and her uh Tik
Tok Channel which exposed me to many
other things I didn't want to be exposed
to so that one was pretty bad uh let's
go to the next one I've had a lot of
people comments on my room and how messy
it is I'm pretty sure it comes from the
aunties who are like are you proud of
this you're disgusting how can you let
it get like this I'm not proud of you
know how messy I let my room get I think
if you have depression or you suffer
from depression or anxiet iety or any
kind of mental health disorder you
understand that sometimes we just can't
get up but finally have the energy after
months this might be it this might be
the most annoying one of the year and
and any Tik Tock uh like it well no we
just can't we just can't you don't
understand well first of all do you
realize that you're doing the thing
right now that you say you can't do
clean up your room that's a good start
it's fact it's like it's not even any
more effort to just put it in the hamper
it's almost no additional effort it's
actually it's possible you can do it no
it's you can do it it's just that when
you for this woman when you're feeling
quote unquote depressed you don't want
to do it anymore and the truth is I am
lazy but not wanting to do something is
not the same thing as not being able
to all right let's go to the next one hi
Benji here and I'm going to explain what
digital blackface
is you will digital blackace is when
non-black people use images or emojis of
black people to express emotion online
often extreme ones like anger or
disbelief sometimes images are edited to
indicate Blackness for this all right be
mindful that when you use a meme with a
black person in the meme or use a a gif
be mindful of how your GIF is
affecting him is he like hunched over
from the burden of all the gifts that
are being used you know the one thing
when you see these kinds of videos they
never explain why we should care like
who put you in charge
never explain that do they have you ever
craved a nice barbecue uh Sunday night
dinner with the family say you go to the
store get all the groceries invite your
family over you go to turn on the grill
your propane tank is empty that's where
cinch comes in to save the day cinch is
a propane grill tank Home Delivery
Service they deliver propane tanks right
to your door C delivers on your schedule
it does not require any long-term
commitment or subscription plus delivery
is completely contactless you don't have
to wait around at home track the order
on the Cinch app from any anywhere
whether you're uh grilling camping with
your family lighting up your fire pit on
a cold winter night CA propane delivery
service ensures you have the fuel you
need to make the most of every moment go
online to cinch.com or download their
app to order new customers can get their
first tank exchange for just $10 with
promo code Walsh that's Cyn ch.com promo
code Walsh this is a limited time offer
and you must live within a cinch service
area to redeem it visit cinch.com
sloffer for
details
I have first of all I have no memory of
ever playing that video I don't know
what that video that's a that's a roller
coaster you don't know what's going to
happen next I still don't know what
exactly happen happened there or what
any of that was I I'm not sure I would
even call it annoying that was just it
was confusing and disturbing and up for
myself he threatens to call the police
and revoke my
membership do you need
something do you need
something no do you need something do
you need something no okay I thought
so okay yeah so this is this is another
genre that took over Tik Tok this year
this is this is the genre of women going
to the gym and recording themselves at
the gym and trying to set up like
entrapping men they wear basically
nothing at the gym they're wearing their
underwear at the gym they record
themselves and they're they're using
themselves as bait to get some man to do
something that they can then paint as
sexist or misogynist that might actually
be the winner but we'll see let's go to
the next one this is my day in the life
as a stay-at-home girlfriend and the
first thing I do is take my aloe shot I
love having this on an empty stomach
then I get straight to making Luke's
coffee because he's definitely a
caffeine first thing in the morning kind
of guy then I sit down and do some
journaling and some reading all right
another in the day in the life category
but this is yeah here's the uh the
stay-at-home girlfriend look if you're
if you're a
man and uh you have a stay-at-home girlf
friend you deserve everything that's
coming to you I hate to say it but this
is this is a woman who's made no
commitment to you whatsoever and yet
you're allowing her to live in your
house and you're supporting her so she
doesn't want to go all the way and
commit herself to you but yet you're
still supporting her as if she has and
so she's using you and then when she's
had enough she's going to go off to the
next guy and you're going to be crushed
by it but you'll deserve it okay next
one okay I'm kind of about to call out
all men sort of so if that's going to
trigger you or bother you Mo
[Music]
along I was FaceTiming my mom and
sisters last night and we are planning
Mother's Day dinner so we're deciding
what we're going to eat what time it's
going to be I'm bringing a food
assignment my sister's bringing a food
assignment my mom's preparing the main
meal why is it this way why can men not
be better than this and yes I love my
husband he's a great guy he's really try
I actually think he's and we're like
Progressive we're like working on and my
husband's on a work trip right now now
my mom's husband my stepdad like tore
his ACL whatever there's like maybe
reasons but if I was on a work trip or
my mom tore her ACL we would still
probably be planning it especially if it
was I do I remember this one yeah how
could we forget how could we forget my
husband is physically not here my step
that is hobbled he like he can't move so
maybe there are reasons why he's not
making dinner whatever there might be
reasons there might be no there are
reasons like one of them is physically
not present the other one is like you
should be making dinner for him hey baby
doll what's for dinner you want dinner
you know if that's something you'd like
if that's something you'd like to do on
Mother's Day just say so it's not hard
all right last one I don't trust white
people I don't trust white people for a
multitude of reasons but one of the main
reasons is they're unpredictable like I
think about all the times where I really
considered white people my friends and
then when we got in a small argument
they released all the racism they hid
throughout our whole friendship also I
think about the fact that white people
have continuously
when given the opportunity oppressed
multiple marginalized communities like
if they really want to they would bring
slavery back I will legit always be
scared of white people until they're the
minority uh you know if you're if you're
someone like that you should be you
should just be grateful I'm amazed that
she has any friends at all like how do
you everything about you is incredibly
unpleasant no hard feelings but I hate
you not joking bye that's a pretty bad
one too I I think ultimately the winner
though and I'm going to go with the Dark
Horse I think the winner of most
annoying Tik Tok it's the it's the
depression Tik Tok maybe it's just the
dad and me talk but it's the making
excuses for not putting your dirty
clothing into a
hamper that's the winner that's what I
Crown the winner most annoying Tik Tok
of 2023 we'll find out what happens in
[Music]